hey everyone welcome back to app
inventor's hour of code
enough of that stop
the next app we build is going to be a
game app
no talking this time no sorry
let's get going on this silent app
to get started log on to app inventor
and click new project
name this one ball bounce
this app is going to have a ball moving
around the screen
the ball will be what we call a sprite
in app inventor ball and image sprites
can only live on a canvas before we put
in a canvas there's a setting we need to
change on the screen properties
it's small but very important for an app
with a canvas
go to the screen properties scroll down
to the bottom part of the properties
list
and uncheck scrollable
this makes it so that the screen will be
a fixed size and will not allow the user
to scroll up and down
okay
now drag out a canvas from the drawing
and animation drawer
notice that it looks very small go to
the properties pane of the canvas and
change the settings for both width and
height to fill parent
that opens up our canvas quite a bit
now drag out a ball sprite and drop it
onto the canvas
it's kind of small let's make the ball a
little larger
go to the properties for the ball and
change the radius to 10.
okay for now that's all we need time for
the blocks
on ball one to view its blocks
pull out the ball one dot flung
yes we named it flung
it may be a silly word but it is
grammatically correct
now think about what we would like the
ball to do after it is flung we'd like
it to move in the direction of the fling
with a speed that matches the strength
or quickness of the fling gesture
the way to do that is to get the
parameters of the fling gesture and to
plug them into the ball's heading and
speed
first pull out the setter blocks for the
ball's heading
and for the ball's speed
we want to set the ball's heading and
speed to the heading and speed of the
fling gesture
there's actually a really easy way to do
this in the flung event handler
pull out the get heading and plug that
into
setball1.heading
pull out the getspeed and plug that into
the setball1.speed
so now we have the event in place that
will handle when the ball is flung by
the user
this means that the user uses their
finger to flick the ball
that's a flick like a pull cue not like
an angry bird launch if you are
connected to your phone then you can
test your app out
how easy or hard is it to fling the ball
does the app respond the way you expect
it to
one thing that you'll probably notice
right away is that when the ball hits an
edge it gets stuck there
we have to tell the ball to bounce off
the edges
back to the blocks
go to the ball blocks and choose the
when ball one dot edge reached block
go back into the ball blocks and drag
out the callball1.bounceblock
notice that this bounce block takes an
edge as an argument
where can we get that edge value do you
think
well how convenient the edge reached
event handler reports which edge was
reached mouse over that edge parameter
and you'll see the get block for it
pull that one out and plug it in
that's all test your app out again
hey look the ball bounces off the edges
now
pretty cool huh
okay so now we've got a very basic game
app going here
but this could be the start of a whole
bunch of different games
the app inventor website has a tutorial
that shows you how to make this into a
mini golf game
you could probably also imagine a game
of pool or a pong game
this is just the beginning
challenge yourself and make this even
more engaging and fun
we're out of time on this tutorial so if
any of you out there would like to
extend your ball bounce app go to our
website for more great ideas definitely
worth checking out in our next and final
tutorial we're going to show you how to
make an app called digital doodle that
lets you make pictures on your phone
sounds great okay we're out for now see
you soon
you